[Music]
why is DC Comics Assent oh I can't
answer that one can't even explain it a
little bit no all I can say is if it
makes you laugh then why does it matter
if it doesn't make you laugh then you're
probably part of the reason the other
people are laughing where is the wizard
music video you know promising us for
over two months one's my bat alright I
got excited and I started teasing early
before I realized post-production like
color correcting and effects and stuff
and the real world can actually take
some time so that's my fault that's a
good all on me
so it is coming yeah yeah you'll be here
next month July for sure book it write
it down can you tell us what it's about
I can't tell you that I mean all I can
say this it's based on something that
was said in one of our previous videos
and it's one of the most pointless
things we've ever made awesome at least
certainly not I have been possible at
this point it looks good because we
heard Pro to shoot it but you know
nobody asked for this nobody would ever
have asked for this are you an honest
trailers connected no only in mutual
admiration and we're both channels that
make fun of movies and we both like
boobs your channel is about to pass
500,000 subscribers how the hell did you
get so many subs so quickly that's it
that's all you got yeah good wine why
would happen if I knew what happened I
wouldn't have done it sooner I mean it
happened and yeah I'm pretty happy about
it I'm gonna run with that but I know
how it happened
[Music]
five hundred thousands really a lot of
people click the button yeah button
click represents more than just a click
that's their endorsement of you they're
saying we like you you want to see more
of your content you want to like show
them you let them know that say thank
you no really thank you kind of guy they
know that dude that's exactly why it
would matter if you actually said it
thank you
[Music]
don't ask a cat to bark and then be
upset when he meows be fast
[Music]